how's it going guys it's been a while
since we did a programmer
humor episode on this uh channel so
i'm going to look at our programmer
humor
and react hold on let's turn on some
lights
it's too dark in here can't see
my own face okay
so what do we got we're going to scroll
through do some reactions and
try to have a laugh or maybe a cringe
we'll see
you never know the first one dunder soft
inc
the cast of the office looks like
they're about to drop the hottest
software update
of 2007
2007. wow
yeah that's a good one
409k slacking off at work oh yeah oh wow
oh wow it's home okay
promoted promoted
get out of here this isn't promoted
no real awards have been ever been sent
credit to forgot dude's name
how coffee works coffee magic
code note that the lack of anything
passing through the brain
oh that's good how to hard boil an egg
duplicate how long
should i cook a turkey how can i tell
they still fresh i want a hard-boiled
egg with my breakfast how long should i
put it in
before wait okay i'm gonna see what the
rest of this is
what okay hold on one of these has
negative four thousand i gotta read that
one in a sec
you're asking the wrong question what it
is you're trying to achieve with this
breakfast
hard-boiling an egg is known as an
anti-pattern this isn't even a properly
breakfast related
thank you for this it's so annoying when
someone gives you a hard-boiled egg i'm
surprised the person asking this
question hasn't been fired yet
boiling eggs is not recommended and
under any circumstances you can fry
poach or scramble or perhaps make an
omelet
trying to boil an egg is a sign of
inexperience
and more results and bad things
happening how long does this keep going
okay let's look at this negative four
thousand one
seven minutes
increase the size of that okay seven
minutes if you want
it slightly sticky going up to ten
minutes or properly hard
hi welcome to stack overflow please take
time to read the rules before posting
so that you don't make such a big fool
of yourself next time
we're friendly bunch here so it's okay
if you're an inferior human being and
clearly don't know what you're doing
just be sure not to post here again that
would be great
thanks
[Music]
oh everybody uploaded the crap out of
the ridiculous answers and downvoted
the actual answer that's all right
[Music]
okay sort of funny but
okay all right why what october to
december is usually a big blur anyways
officer someone used floats to store
dates
and you thought this was a police matter
jesus
christ hello fbi we got a situation way
above my pay grade
[Music]
all right this utilities company only
lets me pay via credit card online and
then demands a 3.5
fee for convenience despite it being the
only stated method
the good news is that they allow
multiple payments towards a single bill
so guess who wrote a script to make 1785
payments of 14
cents i'm guessing
okay
i'm not entirely sure i see the point of
this i'm guessing the 3.5
percent of 14 cents rounds down to zero
and that way he can get no convenience
fee
if that's the case well nice
all right meme the hidden rule came up
three rules
no wishing for death no falling in love
no bring
back dead people i want javascript to
support multi-threading
there are four four rules
uh only finishing a code project at 4 am
error checking
0 comments 0 sleep 0.
i like that the world doesn't know the
horrors of it you can't keep doing the
same thing expect different results
let me introduce you to debugging
that too close to home let's move on
and it's friday afternoon bug in
production
team lead me in and out
20 minute adventure
we know how that goes
it do be like that every stack overflow
answer about bash
answer one use var
whatever comment number one no it's
more jargon common number two no it's
more jargon comment number three no it's
even more
yeah sounds about right
macros everywhere okay this is a parent
child process
import as something
as mom import though as is dad
class sophia mom dot jean staton jeans
welcome home
definite excel hello world live true
self true wild true self go to sleep
yield bardack
self be awesome it's a pretty cool
little onesie
promoted this isn't a this isn't a
programmer
get out of here okay got bored at work
today
my project manager stressing about bugs
in production
me making memes about them instead of
fixing them
uh websites nowadays be like cookies
please accept our cookies
developer okay sorry wrong window
developer get push origin master force
developer
sorry wrong window every other developer
in the
chat channel what are you doing
push origin master force yeah that's uh
big no-no on production
you always have bugs to crush your hopes
when you run your program it doesn't
display any errors don't do that to me
don't give me hope
may the merge begin matt penning says
once a year for 12 hours any pull
request will be accepted
without any review whatsoever all tech
debt
is legal introducing the merge
we all dream about it we're canceling
daily stand up
why do people hate daily stand up i
think i do
is it because uh well there's probably a
multitude of reasons i mean some some
things are great and you can finish them
in one day and
and at the next stand up you'd be like
well i finished that now i'm working on
this and it sounds good
but a lot of the time it's going to be
like well i thought i could finish this
but i couldn't so i'm still working on
it
and the next day well i thought i could
finish this but i'm still working on it
and so it's just like i'm getting tired
of these stand-ups can i just go work on
my thing and
and not have to publicly embarrass
myself every morning
but also the point of the stand-up is
like if you're stuck
maybe someone else has the answer you
don't have to spend days on it because
joe in accounting can be like oh i
understand how that works i don't i
don't know why i know stuff about
programming i'm in accounting and that
is
stand up but that's the example that
came to my mind and it's a bad example
deal with it
all right javascript if human beings
evolve new organs
as frequently as they do javascript
frameworks
you can bet the doctors would be
googling it too
too much pain developer i finished the
project is ready for qa
qa i've run all the tests project
contains no
known bugs now the end user
too much pain causes too much pain and
agony don't know why it's so popular
nowadays i'm going to use
toilet paper oh god
ai mldl propaganda summarized when
you're
fundraising it's ai when you're hiring
it's ml
when you're implementing it's linear
regression
all right couple more okay
users supersonic 16 made this when
talking to someone saying python is
better than c sharp
mom there's a monster under my bed it's
hiding
the most tittiest thing i've ever seen
why do you hate me brother
indentation error expected an
indentation block syntax error
missing parentheses in call to print did
you mean
print python
ah what i don't know what's mean
but whatever oh more promoted thanks
reddit
way to tank your own website with
advertisements and
promotions what is this facebook looks
like facebook
all right thanks for helping me pretend
i know how to code processing.pi
programmers p5.js programmers
lovely all right and here's everyone
else holding them
up they're beautiful land c plus
programmers.net programmers interpretive
programmers people who know
what machine code is
oh so true
yeah well the nice thing about these
frameworks is you can
test out algorithms but yeah with these
ones
well i don't know especially c plus plus
and machine
code you really have to understand how
memory works it's just not all taken
care of for you
been on the job hunt for three months
made this to some of my experience with
recruiter
hello have an amazing junior level
opportunity for you are you interested
yes tell me more this position requires
five years of experience
all right i'm gonna head out
yeah okay no comment
name this song try assert real life
assert fantasy
catch landslide exception
region reality while true characterize
for each
open orient direction sky self.wealth
equals null
self.sexy equals mail sympathies.clear
f come difficulty equals equal
and go difficulty equals easy and
self.high is less than one and lows less
than one is this the caught in the
landslide
i guess i don't know switch wind
direction
all the cases are going to go
mess self.matter equals false anywhere
the wind flows it doesn't even matter
oh that's great me at 3am
coding the most complex algorithm me
later while debugging
yeah that's that's pretty accurate
the first guy to get a stack over low
exception must have been like
you could stack overflow exception for
the first time
wow senior developer when you're 12
but have five years of coding experience
all hail the pyramid
wow it's beautiful
my life story new feature
bugs all right that's gonna do it for
this episode
proudly sponsored by spam on reddit
get your frontier internet today slow
frequently disconnects you can't stream
you can barely watch
youtube frontier thank you
have a good one guys keep on coding and
i hope to see in the next episode of
programmer slammer goodbye